[音楽]
ん
はぁ
[音楽]
あと所そうです皆さん学校のテストを受けたこともありますでしょうか
学校のベスト何が重要かと言いますとゲストまで勉強することも大事だと思うんです
けどもう一つ大事な要因があるんですそれは
周りの環境テストまで普通に受けると気になるの
この人とか前の人とか後ろの人が前の環境ですごい大事だと思うんですよテストにおい
て例えばで
ただりに一緒に勉強してた様がいるとすごく心強いと思うしまたはめちゃくちゃ嫌いな
奴がいるからすごい嫌だと思うんですよねそれだけその天井響くんじゃないかなと思い
ます
まして自分の好きな人とがめっちゃ可愛い子が隣にいたりフリントもらったかで渡す
ときに彼はいい人がいたらメンタル結構プレイと思うんです test 2
なので今回は周りの生徒たちでテストの点数はどう変動するのか実験してみたいと思い
ますねこれけっこうマジで変わると思うんですよね英語のテスト軟水が同じようで2分
したネイマールは生徒の環境を変えって何体がテストやってみよう
と思いますそれによってその点数が生まれの人によってどう変化するのか
今回は+壁ていきましょう伊豆4種類ぐらいパターン想定してるんでまぁこれって科学
的に周りの生徒達のペットのですが変動するかどうかってのがわかるたので2件制服女
学生の皆さん是非チェックしてるだけ
[音楽]
ええええええ
ございます
g
女性ええで
the ぜひ
一人だけ送電みんなインフレーターでよく行く際
ん
4日
お前だけ風人はないと思う
それぞれフェスを始めたら入ってすと味めっ
[音楽]
あっん
わり算
なんか大家さん
ウィローそのキーがはい大丈夫デース
ai
いや一人やりやす1人はイエスね
もう集2力の次元が違った時間内に綺麗に終わることができました一番いいまであると
しているデルのた早速次の環境でテストを受けてみましょう
[音楽]
あ
それはやれてくださいい
概要氏は当時て後ろから前にあるんですか
[音楽]
結果乗ってたら
反動があっ
やっと作れさんん
me
ああああああああ
いやいやキャンシーの中に行ってみたんですけどやりやすかった
本当に館りんごできますよねみんなが活気世論のはちょっと前者であったんですけど
まぁや見やすかったのでレジャー
次の患者に行きましょうん
じゃ jr
[音楽]
プリントもらったで渡すとにも可愛い人がいたらメンタル結構プレと思うのて一つ
それでは始めてください
[音楽]
[拍手]
それではやめてくださいっ
はぁ
あって
後川ずだった
ええええええ
[音楽]
[笑い]
me
wh
ame
me
[笑い]
[音楽]
ん
ああああああああ
tai
パリィ
持っています
エイ
[音楽]
ています
てくださいません
[音楽]
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
ています
バッハ
うんっ
うんうんっうんっ
すみません
まず大丈夫ちゃってずんだですこれえええっ
ブーンっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
えっくす
うん
ん
[音楽]
th
あっん
って
ん
私もちゃん
[音楽]
ran 大丈夫大丈夫ん
多分
ん
あった
持っていません
[音楽]
うん
それでは宅のやめてください
あ
後ろください
から前におりません
[音楽]
4ででっ
うん
[音楽]
me
ni
ああああああああ
はいと言うけどおつかれさまでした無事終わりました一人で行った時と男子ばかりの
ときはやっぱりそんな面たら大丈夫だったんですけど
ae 女の子の時はやばいですねいい匂いがしたんですよ
水着に関して本当にどこを見ても僕的には真面目にやろうと思ってるんですけど本当に
ボンドっていうのはあるなぁと言いますかさんと手が止まりましたねただの大事な
テストの結果でございます周りの人の環境によってどれくらい鉄の定数が変動するのが
早速結果を見ていきましょう
まず一人で受けた時ですね一人で受けた時の点数は100点
点満点中70点でございましたまあもういいんじゃないですかまったく勉強じゃなくて
70てセンター試験ができればやばいですよ続いて男子生徒で受けた時ですあー
62点ですねはいはいはいまあノア
疲れましたね勉強しないでちょっとね2回もセンター試験ぽいのおけるだったが出回ら
なかったってのをやりやすかった方だと思うんですよね続いて
まあ霊夢女子生徒だった場合の点数です
おっ64点意外と関係ないのからなんなら断捨離2点たかったんでちょっとやる気が出
たようなところがあったかもしれないですねばリーグ男子でもまあリングとしても点数
が変わらないことが分かりました釣りで周りが全部水着の女の子だったら
6 dk
周りの人は関係デー
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ